I'm all the knock down I've been asked
to help give the award for outstanding
performance by an actress in a leading
role the nominees are not tonight but
that night at the Hollywood Roosevelt
Hotel on Hollywood Boulevard the
nominees were Louise Dressler in a ship
comes in Gloria Swanson and Sadie
Thompson Janet Gaynor and Street angel
Janet Gaynor in seventh heaven and Janet
Gaynor in Sunrise and the winner is well
I don't really need an envelope
the winner is Janet Gaynor
welcome thank you very much Walter and
thank you all
I'm so happy that both the Academy and I
survived to celebrate this golden
anniversary
you have no idea have difference this is
from the blossom room that night I
competed for the first Oscar with Louise
dresser and Gloria Swanson King Vidor
was there and of course my two glamorous
co-stars Charles Farrell and George
O'Brien and but enough I had my night
tonight belongs to this year's nominees
correct nominees for outstanding
performance by an actress in a leading
role are and bankrupt in the turning
point Jane Fonda in Julia
Diane Keaton in Annie Hall
Shirley MacLaine in the Train boys
Marsha Mason and the goodbye girl
you